his life story under the grapefruit tree
the cc sabathia story
premieres tonight at 9 eastern time on
hbo available to stream on hbo max the
great
cece sabbathia here on the rich eisen
show how are you cece
good what's going on rick thanks for
having me yeah thanks for thanks for
doing this um
when did you decide to do this i know it
follows you around in in 2019 right so
when did you decide to uh to endeavor
this
project actually i i decided like at the
end of uh
18 um going into 19 i know i was going
to retire and then i had the
scare of my heart where i had to stand
put in my heart and
you know i was in the land in the
hospital room with my wife and just
thought like
you know if if i get back if i get out
of here and get the pitch and
you know get a chance to get to 3 000
strikeouts or 250 wins i thought it'd be
cool to be able to document some of that
stuff
you know not for a documentary but just
for my family just for us to have
and you know we started filming and got
halfway through the season
of stuff that we had and thought it'd be
cool to kind of tell the whole story you
know i had never
talked about you know my my stay in
rehab really
um you know to a full extent like i am
tonight
um so i thought it'd be good to kind of
tell the whole story of
you know my life and and uh you know hbo
thought it was good enough to
to pick up you know major league
baseball partner with us so i'm excited
for people to see this tonight
so the scare 90 blockage correct in your
heart
cece sabathia what what is that is that
genetic
plus just your diet and things like that
um and yeah and plus my diet um i
i actually was getting on the plane to
go to london
uh the day before they put the stint in
the doctor told me if i get on that
plane i i don't make it so
um yeah i mean you know pitching at the
weight i did for
in all of my 20s and you know most of my
30s
um you know put me in that in that
position to have 90 blockage and just
lucky enough that i caught it when i did
so was that for the london games is that
what you're saying before you went on
there or i don't know
i was going out there to do like promo
for the london games i was actually
going for
um it was man you was playing um
liverpool i think and and uh and they
had us going out there to do like a
promo it was actually me and jackie
bradley
um and i went uh i was going out to the
stadium
actually to play catch because it was
off season and
you know just wasn't feeling well and
saw the trainer and he called the doctor
and i got a stress test right away
and they were like you need to stay here
we got to put a stint in uh right away
wow and now how much weight have you
lost now cece
how many um uh so when everything ended
at the end of the season last year i was
about 3
11. um right now i'm down to 280. so
um you know i want to be around 275
i don't want to get like all frail and
sk and skinny look at last time i got
down i think the the lowest i got was uh
263 in like 2014 but
i was looking all like frail so i want
to you know try to keep my mask and my
frame
um but just lean out a little more no
and in all seriousness do you think you
needed to be
300 pounds to get the numbers that are
cooper's town worthy
cece do you think yeah and i mean it you
know
the it was kind of documented that way
you know every time i try to lose weight
i just didn't respond like you know for
whatever reason and
to be honest my knee got worse you know
we were we were we would lose the weight
to
try to take pressure off my knee and you
know different things but
you know every time i got really small
uh my body seemed to hurt more
my knees seemed to hurt even more so um
you know yeah pitching pitching in
between 305 and 290
was you know optimal for me so uh let's
talk career here
cece's about the hbo is under the
grapefruit tree um
you know the documentary is called that
because you started
learning how to throw uh by grabbing
grapefruits
was it vallejo california right where um
where
where you grabbed grapefruits on your
grandmother's yard and started throwing
it
why baseball do you think it was just
your calling or or what
what do you think it was definitely just
my calling but growing up in valeo
uh that's that's the sport we played um
you know we were good basketball players
good football players but
baseball was our sport you know starting
even in like little league i mean that
was just
you know all the dads out at the park
you know all the kids i mean even like
you know
me as the t-ball you know kid i would go
out there and play the early game and
then stay all day at the baseball field
so it was just like ingrained in us as
kids that baseball was our sport
and yeah i mean baseball always came
easier to me you know i played all three
sports i played soccer too
um growing up but baseball was just you
know i could just go out there and do my
thing always and felt very confident
were you always
this size i mean how quickly did you
become
you know the grown-ass man you became
see you know what i i was
big but i mean i grew up around some big
ass kids too so i wasn't like
the biggest um yeah you know not until
not until high school did i really like
separate to be honest but
all the way up until until my freshman
year i was you know
probably third or fourth biggest i mean
even in high school we had you know a
seven foot center so i played power
forward in high school
okay all right and then uh obviously you
you go to cleveland and you start uh
winning games and you start making a
name for yourself why
ultimately did it not work out with you
in cleveland
was it my money situation what was it
cece i think it was just you know
that's just how they kind of play
everything out where you know
they sign you early never let you get to
arbitration um
and then you know give you some some
some comfortability like you as
a as a young player um but you never
signed back there as a free agent kind
of like with windows going through right
now
um you know santana went through it i
mean we all
you know every every guy that comes up
in that organization you go through it
and
you just know at a certain point you're
either gonna get traded or you know
they're gonna let you go because they
can't they can't afford to really sign
free agents like that they do a great
job of
you know raising talent and and uh
you know their minor league is always
great but they just never
really resigned the guys and then you go
to milwaukee 130 innings pitched in just
half a season did they just squeeze
every last bit out of you
did you think they overthrew you just
try to push the pedal to the metal
knowing that you were gonna go somewhere
else what do you think
you know what it wasn't i wish i could
blame it on them it wasn't them it was
me i wanted the ball
you know um it was my decision i went in
the dale swings office and and told them
you know i'm going on three days rest
when i figured out that sheets couldn't
go you know his shoulder was hurting
um but that that team we had so much fun
that team was so close
and it's weird because you know i came
up in cleveland spent seven and a half
years there really ten years there
because i got drafted about 17. and then
i get to milwaukee and i felt like i had
been there for 10 years
and i didn't want the season to end and
you know i was feeling strong obviously
i was
you know in the middle of my career so i
was like you know what give me the ball
i'll go
you know i had no problem uh taking the
ball and that's why everybody
always tries to blame it on milwaukee
but it was more me wanting the ball
and and you know my agent was freaking
out at the time but i was feeling good
and felt like i could win every game
well i mean you did you you had to know
on the back your mind the yankees were
going to come hard at you anyway no
matter what right
you didn't know that you had to yeah i
knew that
and and uh you know even at the trade
deadline um
you know we almost had something worked
out uh before i went to milwaukee but
um you know i wanted to test the free
agent market and you know
get a chance to see what was out there
and but they just blew everybody out of
the water the first day of
free agency and really just killed my
market and and
you know this was the only place i could
come sure
absolutely cece sabathia here on the
rich eisen show what do you think is
your signature yankee moment
cece um what do you got for you know
what i think people will always remember
you buying this is crazy because i don't
i don't want to be remembered by this
it's hitting uh
jose sucre i think i think that i think
people will always remember me by that
but
you know for me i just want people to
remember me as i walked off like just
leaving everything out there you know i
left my shoulder out there
my heart my knee you know everything is
literally
you know out there in the bronx at
yankee stadium so i would want people to
remember me how i walked off
the hurting and and giving them
everything i got most talented guy you
played with
where you're like that guy is a natural
which one
who is it he could even be okay
why is that he just his baseball iq not
i mean
we all know what kind of player he was
but his baseball iq was off the charts
um
my rookie year um i went 17 games and um
and and uh i'm the game three starter i
think
um in the playoffs and i'm pitching in
cleveland and i'm nervous first inning
i think i'll walk the bases loaded maybe
even walked in the run
and i remember walking off the field and
i'm like man i don't know how i'm gonna
get through this like i was just
you know i was 21 years old i'm super
nervous and and robbie comes up to me in
a dugout
and he said do not shake off enor the
rest of the game
and i was like what what do you mean he
was like i'm calling the pitchers from
second base
don't shake them off don't think about
nothing just throw what he what he puts
down
and he called the game for the rest of
the game and i go six innings gives up
give up
uh two or three runs and you know we win
the game by a huge margin but
he literally called a whole playoff game
for me from second base what about judge
talk to me about aaron judge
cece what about him judge is a beast man
i think you know
when he's healthy and he's right um you
know if he can play a full season he's
gonna win the mvp
um you know if you know 2017 and people
not banging on trash cans he went to mvp
that year so
you know he can do stuff on a baseball
field that nobody can do and nobody that
i've never seen about nobody hit a ball
as hard as he can
consistently as he can and have as many
good as that as he can so it's just it
was all about health for him
cece you opened a door about banging on
trash cans and i know you
you speak your mind certainly on this
subject i got to ask you as a die-hard
yankee fan
when uh jose altuve hit that home run in
2019
and that was the end of i guess your
career that was your last season in
major league baseball
they show a shot of her all this chapman
who's got like this little smile on his
face
and i know a lot of yankee fans were
like what's he smiling about i knew
exactly what i thought that smile meant
that that's a smile of a picture he goes
man that kid that
that that hitter knew exactly what i was
about to throw is that what that smile
was
is that do you think what that smile was
you know you know there's been so much
speculation about 2019 but i don't i
don't know anything about 2019
you know obviously we know it was
evidence and we know what happened in
2017
um and that's the only thing i could
really speak on you know
i don't know what chappie was thinking
what his expression was or anything like
that but
you know i do know in 2017 if you watch
i i i feel like we were the better team
you know when we when we got them in the
yankee stadium
um you know when there wasn't any of
that going on
you know it wasn't even close so um you
know that that's the only thing that
frustrates me
so what do you say to people saying if
you ain't cheating you ain't trying then
what do you hear that when you say that
when when you hear that i mean
yeah i mean getting my signs from second
base is is one thing you know i played
the game for a long time and
you know getting my signs to second base
is one thing but actually live streaming
designs
that's something totally different you
know saying what do you
say that again what what's what's
totally different live streaming the
signs like when you literally are
streaming the signs from the dugout you
know that's something different than
actually you know outsmarting me out on
the field and getting my signs from
second base right
but so you don't you you you can't speak
to whether you think
deep down in your bones cece sabathia
jose altuve knew
what was coming from or aldous chapman
in that man
honestly i honestly rich i honestly
don't know and to be honest i really
don't care
i don't really care that much about 2017
to be honest
but it's just fun to keep bringing it up
cece sabathia here
on the rich eisen show um so uh this
documentary what what do you want people
to know
about it what are you most proud of of
under the grapefruit tree
which is a dynamite doc that starts
streaming tonight
on hbo i think the the biggest thing i
want people to take from the doc
is that if you need help when you
struggle with addiction to definitely
um you know get help and seek it out i
think the hardest thing about
you know going through addiction and
facing addiction is actually telling
somebody that you need help and
you know actually facing the addiction
um you know
the the one thing that i think i'm most
proud about this doc is
being able to tell my dad's you know
side of the story um
you know for the longest time i think
people you know tried to paint my story
as my mom raised me as a single black
mom which
you know for for you know six years of
my life she did and she's an incredible
woman and i wouldn't be sitting here
without her but
i want people to know how huge of a role
my dad played in my life and
you know the dreams that he put in me
and you know it you know made me believe
that
you know i could pitch in the big
leagues it made me believe that i would
you know win a cy young and be an
all-star and you know pitch in new york
and all these different things so
um i'm excited for people to know that
side of my story and get a chance to
really know
what my dad meant to me okay before i
let you go how concerned about the
raiders are you
cece man very concerned should i be
concerned do we need a new quarterback
do we need a new coach no look at you
wow okay yeah no no look i asked him if
you if you thought
no no no no that's the high heat i
understand what it's like to be brushed
back
um no i look i i obviously i think
gruden
um is the right coach i do believe that
okay
um derek carr had an incredible
half a season i have no idea what the
hell happened in atlanta
and at the jets i don't know i mean it
looked like he was the same thing
happened
last year at the jets we lost by four
touchdowns
we came in we came here six and three to
new york i went to that game i'll never
forget
and i had to leave at halftime like the
jets it's the same the two years in a
row
well i mean that that that history goes
way back to before you were born and
maybe when i
when i was born but i don't know because
derek carr was
cece you saw it with your own two eyes
derek carr was a perfect extension
of this offense and if the offensive
line josh jake
let's put it this way josh jacobs is the
real deal okay we can we can we can
agree on that
darren waller is the real deal uh
too i think aguilar has definitely been
you know uh
i guess resurrected um i think abram's
the real deal
um even though he hasn't stayed healthy
i like max crosby
i mean there are some there are some
really good players that mayok's putting
in there and i think gruden knows what
to do with them
um but uh i think derek carr might get
one more crack at it and if not
they you know mariota certainly looked
really good
he looked really really good and crazier
things have happened just look at what
happened uh where mariota came from you
know tannehill has gotten the gig there
it can
it could happen in vegas it really
counts yeah for sure i mean even
you know i know groot likes older
quarterbacks even if you know some
you know if aaron rodgers comes up on
the market a couple years like i mean i
wouldn't be mad at that but
i mean you know like you said josh
jacobs is a beast
waller is a beast like we got some good
pieces it's just frustrating to not be
able to get
get over that hump and anti is tough i
mean our division is really really tough
because it's gonna be good
and obviously pat mahomes is the best
player in the league so
you know it's gonna be tough to be
fighting out of the division every year
too and
so uh last one for you what was it like
being around russell wilson
uh in uh in spring training what was
that like yo russ is awful man
he's a pro like he was you know takes it
very serious
um obviously it was good for you know a
lot of the young guys to see how hard he
works and
he travels with all his you know pts and
different things and
you know he's getting his football work
in before baseball so
it was uh it was fun having him around
to see how hard he actually
you know works at at his craft and it'd
be great
hey cece congrats on on under the
grapefruit tree
and as well as your podcast as well if
you ever
uh need a guest i'm more than happy to
complete the home and home and have you
back here
i really love the way you went about
your business as a yankee and obviously
before that congrats on your doc and i'd
love to continue the conversation with
you
thank you thanks rich for sure i would
love to have you on the pod i mean uh
ryan we've been doing it for three years
now we're just you know trying to
trying to get trying to get good at it
so we'd love to have you on anytime
yeah uh uh if you want uh i'll just you
know leave your number with uh
with uh our call screener and then we'll
we'll connect i'd love it
thanks cece really appreciate it thank
you you got that cece sabathia at cc
underscore sabathia
here on uh on the rich eisen show um
that was great
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here